[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
the America First Nazi party had not
form one half of our legislative branch
because they do not know how to govern
this is a fact we watched it yesterday
we are gonna watch it play out today as
they as the members make their way uh to
the house floor
Kevin and we're gonna see uh we're gonna
watch today again the house floor we're
gonna keep an eye on it here and the
chaplain is praying currently on the
house floor uh praying and thoughts and
prayers go out to Kevin McCarthy
apparently
as the king Jeffries beat him three
times yesterday three times even Matt
Getz agrees that Hakeem Jeffries would
make a hell of a lot better speaker than
Kevin McCarthy make something of that
won't you
I I said for two years if you put
Republicans in charge of the house it
would be absolute chaos
absolute utter [ __ ] chaos and they
have not disappointed we are only in day
two of the 118 Congress and it's not
even open they have not even formed the
118th Congress can't do it
because they're [ __ ] worthless they
do not know how to govern they don't
know they haven't known for decades
just tick the clock back think about all
the Maga Republicans
before Maga existed Newt Gingrich
a highly ineffective
speaker
Denny Hazard was not among a Republican
he was something else but he was
effective at speaker
Paul Ryan John Boehner not effective
Republicans are not effective at
governing here's why folks they don't
want to
the reason why they don't want to govern
is because democracy is their enemy
liberalism is their enemy
when democracy shows its strength
it shows that the Republican party is
weak
they do not want democracy that's why
the Cheeto dust q and honor wants to
tear up the Constitution
and make him King dictator whatever
speaking of the Cheeto dust cue in honor
he put out a statement
and it's all [ __ ] listen this whole
chaos is that Trump chaos machine Folks
at work that's what this is is the Trump
chaos machine at work
he is stoking this division between his
own party members
and he's sitting watching on cable TV
watching his handiwork play out all over
the world
if you don't think
that Donald Trump made deals with Kevin
McCarthy and the 20 members that are
voting against him you do not know you
have not been paying attention the last
six years this is how he governed
he would create a mess
and then he would pit the two sides
against each other and then claim he
didn't do it when me I didn't do this to
the Republican party this is Kevin
McCarthy's fault this is Scott Perry and
Andy Biggs and Matt gatz and Lauren
bobert's fault you get it you got it you
see how it works the only reason why you
know who Anthony fauci is in the first
place the only reason why you know who
Anthony fauci is because he needed
someone to blame
foreign
that's what this is that's why he was
complaining about the 2022 midterms that
it wasn't his fault
and now they cannot form the 118th
Congress they can't do it
Hakeem Jeffries
yesterday three times got more votes
than the majority leader in the house
and it's not because Kevin McCarthy
shouldn't be the speaker
I mean he shouldn't be
but that is not what is happening inside
the Republican caucus
it is it is intentional chaos this is
what Republicans do this is how they
govern This Is How They think government
works this is how they think policy
works it's all about who can get on Fox
News
who's got more Twitter followers
we have put a bunch of nincompoop Nazi
influencers
in charge
of our representation and our government
because the government is us
It Is Us
and it is only a reflection of the
country when the minority ideology takes
the majority in the Congress and cannot
form one
they are broken they are damaged and
they are not a real party
we are a two-party system and we only
have one party right now
only one
that is interested in democracy the
other one has a faction that pretends to
be interested in democracy and the rest
of them want to kill it
they want to gut
democracy
uh right now they're on the floor here's
them they're trying to
get a quorum they have to put a quorum
together to actually start business
um today we will see if they even
adjourn uh reconvene my guess is is that
Kevin McCarthy's career as a speaker if
he ever wanted to be a speaker
absolutely depends on the the floor
adjourning today
tell at least tomorrow he does not have
the votes those 20 votes from yesterday
are still no votes against him
they will vote for a
a ham sandwich over him because Trump
has told them to now the reports this
morning are that Trump has called all
the members and he's trying to get them
to vote for Kevin McCarthy [ __ ] that
is if you believe what he is typing out
on fraud social
if you believe that at face value you
are fooling yourself
that [ __ ] is absolutely
absolutely at the heart of this of this
chaos
this is this is why the Republican party
is broken because of trumpism
because of make America great again is
more important than the [ __ ] country
they're stupid little Nazi fascist
movement is way more important than the
Constitution our government and their
constituents and the country as a whole
listen they can't do [ __ ] they can't
even swear [ __ ] in until they
form a government until they form our
118 Congress
this is this is why
the American people should reconsider
putting Republicans in charge of
anything
absolutely anything
because at a man man baby's whim down in
Mar-A-Lago
he could absolutely Stoke chaos and
division inside their group
an absolutely deemed them ineffective so
that he can blame them on his misgivings
Jesus the reason why the Senate
the reason why the Senate
is sworn in yesterday we watched Kamala
Harris
swear in the new the new United States
senators who won their elections
the reason why they were sworn in
is because Democrats won
that's why
it's because people who are interested
in policy policy making governance
won their elections
otherwise we wouldn't have a legislative
branch at all
there would be no legislative branch
you think Mitch McConnell would soar to
majority leader
under Maga rule what do you think what
do you what the hell do you think Blake
Masters
Dr Oz Herschel Walker were four
what did you think they were for
they were to be loyal to what Trump
wanted and his every whim to play his
stupid little [ __ ] games with our
country and our government
but don't get discouraged
because you know here at the Tony
Michaels podcast sunlight I believe is
the best disinfectant
and of course the media is buying
Trump's statement Hook Line sinker
I don't I don't by his statement not for
one [ __ ] second
not at all not buying it I think it's
all [ __ ] it's all Bluster it's all a
lie and he may even told Kevin McCarthy
that [ __ ]
making Kevin McCarthy think that he
could win today
because frankly if Kevin McCarthy loses
any more votes here especially if people
peel off more yesterday the first two
votes
he he missed it my 19 19 people in his
caucus voted against him
by the third vote there were 20 voting
against him today it could grow to 21 22
25.
hell we started the show yesterday and I
asked Texas Paul I said what do you
think you think there's going to be 10
12. I thought that was a high number
I was way off
you have to remember who was Voting no
to Kevin McCarthy
these aren't these aren't never trumpers
these aren't people who don't get along
with Trump these are people who talk to
that [ __ ] probably on The Daily
on the phone why he's taking a [ __ ] or
acting like he's good at golf
or stuffing a cheeseburger in his mouth
I don't know when he's talking to him
exactly but you know he's talking to him
and you know they're doing his bidding
we watched it we see the evidence the
evidence is being released from the
select committee that these [ __ ]
idiots do his bidding
cause they're authoritarians and they
want authoritarianism
you think Scott Perry who had his
[ __ ] cell phone taken by the FBI and
is under investigation for the
Department of Justice and the grand jury
and Jack Smith
for a for a goddamn Tri attempt of
overturning our election in 2020 you
think that guy isn't going to listen to
Trump
he tried to commit
an Insurrection he helped commit an
insurrection
uh here here we go let's go to the house
floor here thank you
not much enthusiasm behind um
Kevin McCarthy again
as they nominate him
oh boy
so it looks like we're gonna have a vote
folks which I would imagine that this is
gonna be the end of Kevin McCarthy's
career here
if if they do this today
let's all
take a second
take a look around let's see what's uh
what's happening frustrated take a look
at this chamber and realize oh my God
lucky
we are
to serve this country in Congress how
lucky we all are you were so lucky that
you gerrymandered our districts and our
our [ __ ] country up enough to have a
majority of a minority ideology
that you can't even put the 118 Congress
together yes you're so [ __ ] lucky and
so are we
the hell out of here
he's definitely out of order Madam Clerk
I say that because I know last night
people were frustrated they wanted to go
to parties they wanted to take pictures
with their families oh Jesus but
obviously we find ourselves here in this
chamber at the second day all right all
right all right all right Mike Gallagher
from Wisconsin
he wanted to take pictures with his
family and celebrate
because they became members of Congress
they wanted to get sworn in well maybe
maybe just maybe maybe just maybe you
should toss Trump aside and you should
toss the people who love that
[ __ ] aside maybe just maybe your
party should get your party in order we
have done all we can
as the pro-democracy Coalition as
liberals to try to to try to talk sense
into you dumb [ __ ]
to try to get you to understand that
authoritarianism isn't going to work in
democracy it's not you either want one
or the other you have to choose
you have to choose you do you cannot
have both
you [ __ ] boneheads
so decide decide what you want to do
well I think they've already made their
decision
they've already made their decision
they cannot win without all the [ __ ]
megalodites out there voting
all the brainwashed mind [ __ ]
spread Nicks
they just absolutely cannot function
without them they won't win elections
and folks I've talked about this before
there's two things at play here
there there is elections and there is
government
they won elections gerrymandering
bullshitting like George Santos
absolutely [ __ ] lying he's not the
only one by the way Jesus Christ if you
think George Santos is the biggest liar
in the Republican Party
there's 20 guys that voted against Kevin
McCarthy yesterday that don't understand
how government works
Jim Jordan yesterday Andy Biggs first
and then Jim Jordan
Jim Jordan doesn't want to be speaker
Jim Jim Jordan wouldn't wouldn't be able
to work his way out of wet papers that
Jim Jordan could even report sex crimes
for crying out loud
he can't do the right thing he knows it
he knows he's weaked he knows he's inept
why would he want to be speaker
give me a [ __ ] break
I hope they vote now I I don't know if
they'll try to adjourn here but it looks
like they're going to vote I hope they
do hope they do I hope they take three
or four more votes here
Kevin's going to lose every [ __ ] one
of them my guess
it will be the end of Kevin McCarthy's
career
as a congressman he'll serve his term
but that that's it
Sid you you cannot rebound
from such an embarrassment
it's the same way that Trump will never
be president again even if he's their
nominee which he will be he will be
their nominee count on it
they're such a [ __ ] embarrassment
what a bunch of pathetic [ __ ] losers
and here's here's today's biggest
pathetic loser right here Kevin McCarthy
and if you're wondering
if this is bad for government now this
may be a detriment to our national
security folks honestly because we don't
actually have 118 Congress we don't have
Congress people they are not sworn in
they cannot go to regular business
now there's talks of getting a speaker
who used to be a republican Congressman
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] that's all
nonsense that is all a bunch of [ __ ]
people who used to be congressmen trying
to get [ __ ] headlines in the goddamn
news that's all that is
the speaker is going to be someone in
this caucus
a hundred percent
it's gonna be
who it will be I don't know how long
it'll take who knows that's democracy
though folks
it may be a detriment to our national
security because these Republicans can't
get their [ __ ] together
but the fact remains
what you're seeing right now is
democracy I had some people replying to
me on Twitter that oh they just there
needs to be new rules set that after
three votes or some [ __ ] whatever it is
listen
there is a reason why these rules exist
there is a reason why you have to have
major the majority of votes to become
speaker
speaker speaker of the house is not just
the leader of the House of
Representatives
they are one of the most powerful people
in our entire nation they are third in
line to the presidency they are so
powerful do you have any idea the
absolute power that a speaker of the
house holds
most speakers don't even know
Nancy Pelosi was one of the most
effective speakers in our modern history
think about it for a second I think Pete
Aguilera who is on the screen now
actually talked about it yesterday
how Nancy Pelosi
with the same slim majority that Kevin
McCarthy can't put together for his
speakership look at what the Democrats
accomplished in the last Congress
for the American people not for
themselves
for the American people
the pack act for American veterans
the chip back for American Manufacturing
the inflation reduction act free the
American people out there who are
suffering under huge huge prices of
prescription drugs
the coronavirus relief package for
Americans out there who were who who
were financially getting their asses
kicked coming out of the pandemic
all that happened under the same slim
majority that Kevin McCarthy can't even
become the speaker of the house there is
a reason
it's not I mean Nancy Pelosi is the most
effective speaker in our Modern Life
whether you like her or not sometimes I
like her sometimes I don't
the most effective speaker in modern
times
tell me one that was more effective
in the last 30 years
it is imperative that we understand that
what we are watching is our Republic at
work
this is the consequences
that we face when we elect who we elect
this is the consequence of us engaging
or not engaging in our democracy folks
when we put people in power
that absolutely are not serious
about governing they won't govern I mean
Jesus Christ yesterday Lauren bobert who
won by 500 votes was in front of the
microphone at least two dozen times why
the [ __ ] Kevin McCarthy can't go to
Lauren bobert listen if if he could run
a caucus
if she only won her re-election by 500
[ __ ] votes Kevin McCarthy would have
the ability to go to Lauren bobert and
tell her you are going to vote for me
you won by 500 votes in your District
your future as a congresswoman depends
on me becoming speaker
and you will not you will not get in
front of a microphone and say [ __ ]
because you are barely just barely
part of our carpets
and you will not you will not be
speaking
for your entire District as if your
entire District wants
Jim Jordan as their [ __ ] speaker got
it
that's the conversation that I mean
maybe not in so many words
you have to know your votes you have to
know your caucus
and let's see it looks like um chip Roy
has uh nominated someone on the floor
let's see who
he's nominated here
Byron Donalds he's a good man raised by
a single mom Jesus Christ Here We Go
Again move past Byron Donald's is going
to get 19 20 21. and has devoted his
life
to advancing the cause for his family
and for this country
so here we go again
um with with uh more more Trump
candidates that's what this is and
they're just all they're doing is
nominating a second a second person on
the floor as Speaker
so that so that they don't have to vote
other they didn't go very well the first
couple boots are the first vote
so they made sure they had someone to
vote for
and to put a name forward as opposed to
having a broken boat they have to show
some sort of unity even in this
nincompoop Nazi caucus
but this is what happens again when
you've when Texas 21st district votes in
chip Roy here someone who's absolutely
unserious about government
no person serious about government would
be nominating the person that they're
nominating wouldn't
at all
but here we are I mean some people
some people are even floating that Steve
scalise could rise to power here no he's
not not gonna happen police stefanik oh
she wishes
she wishes I mean she sold her soul to
the devil why wouldn't she wish that she
could become speaker of the house here
but we're gonna watch this vote I did I
really didn't think Kevin McCarthy was
gonna he was going to do everything he
could to make sure there wasn't a vote
because this is already a sign with chip
Roy uh nominating one of these 20 I
believe he's one of the he was actually
the 20th one that that flipped yesterday
if I'm not mistaken I might be mistaken
on that
um
but
um we we are we are
um
someone says uh Brian Donald is Herschel
Walker again a chaos candidate folks
what do you if if Georgia would have
elected let's just play this out of
Georgia would elected Herschel Walker
and Pennsylvania would elected Dr Oz and
Arizona Blake Masters what do you think
would be happening
do you think Mitch McConnell would have
Rose to power
as the majority leader again in the
Senate [ __ ] no that was the point that's
why they're so pissed off about those
elections
listen when I tell you that Donald Trump
is going to be their nominee and he is
going to go all the way to the end of
the Earth to do that we should encourage
it
this is democracy this is government
this is our this is our chance
there was a meme that I found the other
day
and I posted it on Instagram
and Facebook
and it says
we have to stop this when when they go
low we go high we have to go for the
throat it is time it is time that Us in
the pro-democracy Coalition understand
that we have to politicize this at every
single step
every single moment
every single piece
of this authoritarian
America First Nazi party
Antics and their chaos all of it
at every step
we'll come back we'll be right back I
promise we're going to come back with
this coverage
of the second day
of Kevin McCarthy
desperately trying
to become speaker don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
as the fourth vote is happening on the
floor of the House of Representatives
where Kevin McCarthy will lose for the
fourth time
and Hakeem Jeffries the Democrat beater
and nominee for Speaker of the House
will win the majority of the votes but
not the big enough majority
to take the seat and speaker
we will watch as the vote happens here
we will give commentary right over top
of the boat
um as it goes because this is a voice
vote just like yesterday
um they will be doing have to call out
names of who they want now um as we
stated yesterday there's two two things
that members of gangers can do here
um they can actually abstain and not
vote or they can vote present which
would lower the vote count that McCarthy
needs to reach the threshold
of majority this has happened before it
happened the last time Nancy Pelosi
um actually got her vote to become
speaker
there were several people who abstained
or voted present uh lowered the actual
majority count of how many she needed
um and but she was still able to easily
whip the boats count the votes know what
her math was and go to the floor and
become speaker immediately
it's been a hundred years now since
a speaker has not been able to get the
seat of speaker on the first ballot it's
how long it's been Kevin McCarthy's the
first one in a hundred years now how
many days and how many votes this will
take
um is unclear
I believe though if McCarthy loses
several times and votes today
um McCarthy will have to step aside and
I know I don't see that he's gonna have
a path forward
pass today's vote I don't see how they
can go to three days of voting against
McCarthy in his work we already got two
votes for um Donald's who's a republican
from Florida Byron Donalds is there is
there foil today
for McCarthy Rochester to give him 20
votes to make sure that McCarthy does
not receive the speakership
there's Lauren bobert just voted for
Donald's
so we will um today I have um a special
guest uh joining us at some point uh
David Bender you know the political
strategist will be joining us
McCarthy
Bowman
he will be joining us also Gabe Sanchez
will be joining us very soon
um to answer the comment uh actually you
know what I think I have uh David Bender
in The Green Room there
um if he's ready and give me a thumbs up
and then I'll uh
he says he's ready he says he's ready
David Bender
um good morning how are you sir uh well
you know the question is how is Kevin
McCarthy and I don't think he's doing
too well today
um either I I was waiting to join you to
see how the bees would go and we got
Biggs and uh boaters among others Bishop
yes we have four votes for Donald all
right Donald's already
um right which they're quite pretty much
destroys Kevin McCarthy's chance unless
we get present votes the question is
Tony Donalds was the one who flipped
yesterday yes he was the 20th vote in
the third round
so we're gonna be on air now when they
get to the Deeds Bush and if you saw
Donald's this is not a man when he was
placed a nomination who looked terribly
happy about it to be the center of
attention
is he going to stay and vote for himself
is he going to vote present or is he
going to flip back to McCarthy
that's the vote to watch right now
uh also we had chip Roy
um which will be in the R's on the boats
nominate Donald's I would imagine since
he nominated him he will vote for him
which puts down
so we're at six so we're at six already
before we even get through the roll
absolutely I really think as long as
Donald's votes we're going to be at 20
hard now we talked about this yesterday
um and even chatted this morning through
text that if Kevin because I did we
didn't know if Kevin McCarthy would
actually do everything he could to
adjourn because I actually think his
speakership if he's going to be speaker
uh actually depended on this adjourning
today because this vote right here if he
continues to do this he's going to have
to walk away from the idea of being
speaker it's second half of the votes
they didn't have the votes to return
Tony well right the Democrats were
whipping uh there would be no Democrats
and losing a procedural vote and going
into the sort of an even worse
so
but isn't it but but
um you know because I I said that this
is democracy at play this is really what
the framers had in mind that you can't
have a party that cannot have they have
to form a government right we have to
form a government and we have a senate
we have an executive branch we have a
legislative branch but we do not have
118th Congress it is not the one they're
not sworn in there are no Congress
people they can't uh uh go to normal
business uh our national security could
be at risk here because we don't have a
congress now but this is democracy and
before our very eyes and that is I I
because someone was tweeting at me
yesterday that they should make new
rules that it should only be three votes
and this and that and I said look there
is a reason why this system is the way
it is for speaker and it's a reason why
this has not happened for a hundred
years because serious people have been
in government and wanting to form
government and do government regardless
of ideology or or or what their their
principles are that the main principle
was that the Constitution and our
government and our security and our
Congress is more important than than
than some man-child down at Mar-A-Lago
throwing ketchup at the wall well and
and he's still doing it today but you
know he is he loves there there was
Donald's Donald's just voted for himself
uh uh David Bender he did Donald's just
voted for himself yes okay so the 20th
vote that was yesterday is now the fifth
vote today uh so far no no Donald's did
not vote for himself yet we're still in
the seas
excuse me you're right you're right
you're right I'm sorry I'm sorry we are
we are at six votes for Donald oh no
question but I I want to see what Donald
does for himself in a minute and and to
your point the the man who sews chaos uh
is still sowing it he he endorsed Kevin
McCarthy this morning saying he's gonna
be good maybe great but he could he
couldn't resist a backhanded endorsement
McCarthy he's just it's unbelievable
well I actually believe and I've told
you this I I think in private Donald
this is the doing of Donald Trump
frankly this is the chaos
um Donald Trump loves nothing more than
to watch his handiwork on cable TV more
than nine loves anything else and and
for the past two days and for for the
next three or four or two two weeks
maybe until we get a speaker his
handiwork will play out on cable TV and
he will get to an enjoy all of it and I
think he's in the ear of both sides of
the Republican caucus question about it
and his name is in the news not as a
subject of an indictment that's right
and just for a couple of days uh it's
sort of much in the same way as the uh
incoming Congressman if he's ever sworn
in from New York Mr Santos uh this is
the only time his name is going to be
used without the uh under indictment uh
you know extradition to Brazil
so so they're loving this period uh both
Trump and Santos did you see by the way
Tony Santos website went up uh thing
saying I I swear this is true you can
probably get a screen cap it went up
yesterday in which he announced that he
had been sworn in by the new speaker
it was an automatic thing that went up
and this is how confident he is I mean I
I don't know who's running his website
oh boy he's the only one it reminded me
of John lovitz's character you know the
lying guy yeah yeah I was sworn in
that's it that's the ticket right well
you know myself
you know I think I think for people you
know Santos and the in the uh lying
drama around Santos
um is hilarious we're going to get to
Donald's here really quickly
uh but I this Santos thing I don't think
he's much of an outlier in the
Republican party I mean he really is he
fits in just he fits in quite well with
these um with these frauds now because
that's really what is happening is he's
done it in a way
if you remember we we had this with
Anthony Weiner for Democrats when you
when you have someone who is such
a a fodder for the tabloids it creates
such fodder as Santa's house I mean
everything people people fixate on that
here's Donald's he just voted for
himself
there we go
and there's a little bit of enthusiasm
in the room yeah
there's probably about 19 people
clapping it looks like yes well 19 other
people exactly right more than that if
there's any more than that
one one more vote for Donald's than the
20 yesterday that voted for Jim Jordan
right then we are talking about the end
of Kevin McCarthy's ambition
if he holds at 20 they they're going to
try and move to adjourn and that's not
going to pass
and I don't know what they're going to
do then it's how many times do you think
they'll vote again today and of course
McCarthy probably if he was prepared to
come to the floor I'm sure he's prepared
to have several other people nominate
him for these votes we even watched
yesterday as after his first vote he
thought he could get Jim Jordan to
nominate him and that would work and
Matt gatz came up immediately and
nominated Jim Jordan the person who
nominated McCartney
um only showing that and again I I know
people might not believe this because
the media has spun this As Trump wants
McCarthy he does not want he wants the
chaos he doesn't care about who's
speaking speaker yesterday that was
Trump's that was Trump's little
injection into the floor vote when Matt
gatz went and and nominated Jim Jordan
after Jim Jordan nominated mccarthur
I'll give I'll give gaps and I'll call
him that uh in in honor of oh yeah
because that's how I call him yeah I
know that but but gats Gates and it
doesn't matter he's still you know
horrible horrible uh representative but
he is showing the abilities in Iowa's he
doesn't really care about the everything
we talked about and you said at the
outset National Security any of it he
cares only about chaos
it is not in his interest now because
he's he's lit the match right so Kevin
McCarthy should he become speaker
is never going to forgive uh Gates chip
Roy uh Andy Biggs this group of people
they've got to keep this going until
McCarthy is gone well right until he
does he because McCarthy really has to
walk away here
um and say you know I'm done don't
nominate me and find someone else to
nominate
um there was some talk that uh former
Congressman Upton from Michigan would be
nominated
um I actually think that's that's just
the media believing Republicans uh
that's not yet that doesn't happen until
they've exhausted their resources if I'm
betting Tony if I'm betting this is
similar to what happened when Newt
Gingrich resigned in the late 90s 98 I
guess uh going into the 99 in January of
99 and the night before uh Bob
Livingston
Matt Getz just he said here's was the
quote David Bender he he cast his
historic vote yeah it's the first time
he's ever voted for any person of color
in his life right exactly right
it's historic for him the content of his
character yeah but but what happened in
99 Tony was that Bob Livingston was
supposed to be the consensus choice
right after uh uh Gingrich it was the
day before he was going to be nominated
an elected speaker Larry Flint exposed
an extramarital affair seems quaint in
these days but it was the time of uh
Clinton and all that was a matter of
fact it was just before actually about
it's just before uh impeachment uh but
the the upshot was they had to find a
consensus and they reached down on the
ranks and found a non-controversial
Denny hastert
because in those days Denny hastert had
no controversy and he became the
consensus Choice who is the Denny
hastert now and I've heard this name uh
actually David Jolly's talked about him
a lot uh Patrick McHenry uh North
Carolina is a uh he's in leadership he's
been whipping for McCarthy but he's well
regarded by a lot of people he's a
consensus kind of guy down the road
stefanik scalise they all have enemies
but you you gotta go way down to see if
you might be able to get someone who can
get to 218 from Republicans if that
doesn't happen that's when you're going
to see uh discussion serious discussions
between the Upton caucus within the
Republicans and the Democrats so here's
my question to you because you've
watched this play out a long time you've
never seen the you know in real time the
drama and the chaos that's playing out
in the Republican party of course they
remember 1920 I remember 1923 right you
know right like it was yesterday right
yeah but here's but here's the thing
here's the thing if if Kevin McCarthy
cannot win a vote today which he
probably will not
I think that this could be two or three
weeks before we form 118th Congress it's
going to take a lot longer than than
what people expect to actually form this
to form this uh part of our legislative
branch do you agree I I I I agree I
think it will take longer but not two or
three weeks okay too many things too
many things uh aren't done literally
people aren't getting paychecks right
now uh staff isn't getting paid people
have lives here that are attached it's a
very different situation than a hundred
years ago 100 years ago there weren't
even full-time staffs you know the first
Office Buildings for the house weren't
built until the 30s those those House
Office Buildings so it was a much
different smaller institution now there
are so many people
whose livelihood depends on it we see
March retailer green sticking with
McCarthy for now uh but that's that's
the difference Tony is that you can't go
three weeks and not fund the government
and not and not have a a congress form
so I think it's like everything in the
21st century it's going to move faster
it has okay well you know I think we'll
get it resolved this week okay maybe
holiday at the latest okay well um I got
Gabe Sanchez here and I know his
favorite uh nominee for Republican uh
speaker of the house is probably George
Santos what do you think um
whip are you gonna whip to get uh Santos
as the nominee on the floor I gotta I
got an inside scoop and I don't even
know why they're going through the
formality of voting from what I
understand George Santos was already
nominated oh really as the speaker of
the house yeah he's already you know he
already hit down the gavel and put
himself in yesterday yeah apparently
David told us that on his website he's
he got he he has announced that he got
sworn in yesterday even though there
wasn't uh
out there last night and it's consistent
with his entire life history Louisiana
entirely invented uh I think I think
that's the consensus Choice everyone
will rally around him uh and you know
he's perfect for you know when we come
down to it since Fred Upton is no longer
member of the house that brings up the
issue that we've all talked about in
theory and it's now reality you do not
have to be a member of the house right
speaker and most people didn't know that
until now but it's always been true and
it could be anyone there were I think
there was a vote for Donald Trump on
that first ballot wasn't there
[Music]
Matt Gates on the campaign Trail while
they were at the Trump rally said I'm
going to nominate Donald Trump and I
have yet to see him actually follow
through with that so I feel a little I
feel a little Hood winked he told me he
was gonna do it and he didn't do it oh
it's it's well the problem is for Trump
he he would have another loss
we'd all love that I thought I'd heard a
vote shout it out maybe it was one not
recorded oh you know who well there was
a vote for Donald's yesterday there was
like an other Donald's so maybe that was
it and there was also a vote uh for
Gallagher shouted out when Gallagher was
nominating McCarthy just a few minutes
ago people people are going to start
naming and they are doing it a lot of
people aren't these supporters are
floating other names right and that is a
sign of very bad sign McCarthy's
loyalists
don't love him absolutely they just
don't and and his someone said again
that you know when you're dealing with
support that is a mile wide but an inch
deep the minute it cracks it's done yep
and it's cracking right now in front of
us well David I I know you're you're a
student of civics
um because you've been doing this for uh
like you said you remember the 1923 vote
where they didn't I remember the second
Grover Cleveland uh run not the first
one so you've been doing this for quite
some time but the Civics lessons here is
that
[Applause]
favorite son of Brooklyn and and there's
and there's more enthusiasm for him
voting for himself than anyone voting
for McCarthy so here's the civics lesson
here tonight because I I kept getting
this in the comments that
um you know
um basically they need to change the
rules again I mentioned this before and
then something needs to happen but this
is democracy playing out before our eyes
this is the Republic that everyone talks
about all the people like we're not a
democracy we're a republic like this is
this is the Republic playing out this is
how our democracy Works Kevin McCarthy
is literally receiving 90 of his caucus
vote 90 but it is still not enough to
reach the threshold of the majority in
the house to give him the speakership
and here's why that's important I
believe in this lesson of civics and I
know you can give us a little more
background on this
but the job of the speaker is to is to
bring legislation and business to the
floor of the house and to whip votes and
to make sure that that legislation
passes through the house
um to make it to the center now
if if we cannot find a speaker
it is not because
um we we are a broken government it is
because our democracy is working and the
reason why I believe it is because what
we have in this country is gerrymandered
districts where the minority of ideology
has been elected as the majority of
Congress uh the 118th to be exact and
that is why Kevin McCarthy can't seem to
whip enough votes to get to 218 because
even though they are in the might
majority of Congress they are the
minority of ideology in this country
their ideas their principles which they
really have none their policies are not
popular
um their constituencies are not strong
either
um and that is and that is what's
tearing them apart because they really
don't have a part one party anymore
um whereas it seems that the
pro-democracy Coalition the Democrats as
it were really if you form if you talk
about parties that is the party that is
pro-democracy that is the party that has
one message one Unity behind them and
that is why we are seeing this chaos
play out it isn't because I mean Kevin
McCarthy is effective as a caucus leader
I guess he was the majority lead or the
minority leader but the problem is is
they don't really have a party
and they don't have a real caucus it's
all pretend it's all fake it's all a
fraud and that is why democracy is so
important and why we must we we must um
consider that these gerrymandered
districts are putting in Us in these
situations where the minority of
ideology is controlling majorities of
legislators and
um even beyond that in this country
I I agree with that uh this is the
Santos party it doesn't it it has no
credibility it doesn't stand for
anything it it invents itself on the fly
it stands against
everything it doesn't stand for anything
and that's that's the problem this is
you talk about uh the job of the
speakers to move legislation they don't
want to move any legislation they have
no desire to do that their sole goal is
to paralyze the Biden Administration
that's their agenda they've made that
clear now let's let's look at what you
just said these gerrymandered districts
Tony uh they that is a disaster but in
places like Michigan where they finally
reapportion based on uh an independent
commission the entire State flipped uh
the Democratic legislature both houses
the governor Statewide offices all went
for Democrats first time in a long time
and that's what we have to move towards
over the next decade is to get away from
these very matters but let me let me
make one point
the 150 uh people who came back after
January 6th approximate 141 I guess it
was who voted not to certified
most of them are back there
many of these election deniers have have
been increased in number by new members
who questioned the validity of Elections
that's the majority of the minority
party actually now the majority party
quote unquote if you call it that but
Republic a majority of Republicans don't
believe that Joe Biden have said so is
the legitimate precedent so they are
that's their organizing principle that's
what drives them they they think Biden
must be impeached everything he's doing
Merrick Garland Tony fauci all of this
has to be investigated it's
anti-everything and people in America
are tired of it that's what the 2022
election return showed if these
districts had been Fair these people
wouldn't be back no right exactly well
Gabe Sanchez going to the the party of
no as as David
um put it there they are the the party
of
of no but as we watch we see that
Donald's is getting 13. it looks like
he's going to get the same 19 or 20
votes here I would imagine he's going to
get 20 because he was the 20th vote and
he's already voted as we as we
um tick through the uh the vote here but
back to the the party of no and
gerrymandering and thinking about this
through the prism of what America wants
and doesn't want and you brought up
Santos as uh why I guess we kind of
played with the ideas Santos
as as speaker right but again Sanchez
Gabe Sanchez you're going to do a what
was that on Santos but yeah it really
and you've been doing your research on
this is it real I mean he has a lot of
republicanism or trumpism and lies and
fraud packed into one candidate and one
person but is any of this fraud and lies
and stuff outliers from manga in general
we had I mean we had people like J.R
Majewski right Mr Stolen Valor who lost
bigly during the midterms you know
thankfully uh he was another one
Herschel Walker which is obviously a
household name now
um through his own
um well I mean he whipped out an actual
fake badge right yeah but that's what
that's honestly what the Republican
party is right it's the you know uh show
of fake badge as a prop to prove that
I'm actually a cop to uh correct or lie
about a lie that I made years ago go and
double down on and then you've got
Santos who says I would I you know born
and raised New York in a basement
somewhere you find out that he's
actually uh you know from Brazil uh
Court Document or there's actual
documents that came to light today via
CNN that actually proved that he
admitted to stealing those checks and
committing fraud in 2008
um you've got these people who not only
commit this this crime lie cheat steal
murder whatever it might be
and then admit to it and that is the
reality of the Republican party and just
just like Bender was saying it is it is
so much this party of no it is
anti-everything it is anti-American they
fight everything they can you saw it the
last two to three months
of uh of the last group in power before
the kind of during the summer really you
saw them
say no to everything whether it was
price gouging or it was uh benefits or
it was uh helping veterans you know the
party the Republican party claims to be
the party of veterans and the military
in America and all these rights but when
given the opportunity to put their stamp
of approval and say yes I did in a
bipartisan way fight for your rights so
that you can be living in the American
dream a better life have better
opportunities they say
no no no no no no no no whenever they
have the possibility
and what exactly and whenever and if you
ever and anyone listening if you ever
hear people that say oh no the
Republican Party didn't say that or
whatever the [ __ ] [ __ ] is you can
literally show them the receipts you can
go to C-SPAN get a screenshot of a final
vote that says 200 plus people said nay
and all of those people were from the
Republican party and the only people
that were voting yay and for that were
of the democratic party they're the only
group that are fighting for social
programs that are fighting for jobs that
are fighting to lower the costs of
everyday American citizens are just like
no no we don't want to do it or it will
better ourselves well you guys can go
[ __ ] yourselves well you know and and I
bet at bare minimum Democrats doing
their job but if you go back to those
screenshots that you were talking about
over the last few years you'll notice
that there was a speaker I believe and
and I think David and you agree with me
on this uh Nancy Pelosi is the most
effective speaker like her or not she's
the most effective speaker in our modern
history in the history of the country
okay well David puts it goes even
further to the history of the country
but Nancy Pelosi was very very good I
was even texting uh Bender yesterday
about the Texas Falls Little theory on
the vote and Democrats voting president
David said he texts me this and and
David I'm telling on you a bit but it he
said trust me Pelosi is counting
yeah she probably had a piece of paper
in her lamp counting and I don't even
know if she needed this paper I'm sure
she's like I'm over here with an Excel
spreadsheet if you've seen her
daughter's documentary which I heartily
recommend uh Pelosi in the house on HBO
Norman uh she there's a scene where she
is counting votes and she says some
people count sheep to fall asleep I
count votes well but that's what the
speaker's job is and that's why Kevin
McCarthy isn't reaching this but back to
the party and no and Santos and and and
and how just repugnant and vile they
have become and versions of themselves
but really the reason why this exists at
all is because they rally around each
other I mean we watch Marjorie Taylor
green the other day on Twitter talking
about how well what about this you know
you're you're knocking on Santos but
what about this and what about that and
what about this and what about that
Santos is is great basically
um because they rally around these lines
they rally around the incompetence
um and I I want to give a different
mirror image of our government
and the reason why is because uh David
you you know
um again the Civics and our government
all too well
um way way back again all the way to
1923 apparently but here's here's here's
what I'll say is that on the other side
of our legislative branch yesterday
Kamala Harris uh swore swore in uh all
the new Senators the senator elect she
swore them in and they came to the floor
it was it was normal business over in
the Senate realm and the reason why is
because Democrats defeated Herschel
Walker Dr Oz and Blake Masters if those
three would have won
we would have the same situation in the
Senate Mitch McConnell would not soar to
majority leader that was the whole point
the whole point of having the manga
chaos candidates was to create manga
chaos inside our government what we're
seeing play out right here on the screen
and but the mirror image is that
Democrats and serious people got elected
and what that means is they are doing
serious work over in the Senate and
they're getting to business of our
government and our work it's our we are
the government us the voters
we are but not if you live in some of
these ruby red districts they are they
are in fact representing their
constituents unfortunately because those
districts have been a portion in a way
that if if Marjory Taylor green goes
home uh to whatever home she's living in
now uh maybe I think she's just Marjorie
Taylor
that that is not
a controversial position for her to take
as a matter of fact she might get some
Flack for supporting MacArthur because
these people are nihilists that's what
they are they are not house members they
are burned down the house members that's
what they want they don't they in in one
respect
the reason they were part of the
Insurrection and encouraged it Scott
Perry who's a part of this cabal right
now as we know is phone is currently
with the FBI
those people
do not want this chamber to work they
were happy to see it desecrated
they are despicable
betrayers of the oath that they haven't
yet been able to take
that's who they are to me and and that's
who they should be
Roger it should be evidence of the
American people that's who they are but
the problem with God is this is all
through a lens now that has been
trumpified so people who are still in
that place it's shrinking but people are
still in that place cannot see
they cannot see what we're saying we can
we can say it we can describe it we can
say they don't want government to work
government is us which means you want to
hurt yourself
Tony I couldn't agree with you more the
government is US say it over and over
and over again because it has always
been true it's an extension of our best
impulses
except when people who are demagogues
like the math game citizen like the Jim
Jordans and the rest take our worst
impulses and bring it into the people's
house that's what we have to exercise
here and it isn't happening yet and and
the reason that I think that we're going
to get to something that some people are
calling on Aaron Sorkin fantasy
something that was that will really
change the way Congress can work in this
118th session
is a lot of those members
who came in this time the ones in New
York for example not Santos he's gone
but the other three one in Biden
districts
they want to stay there for any period
of time they've got to be able to work
with Democrats because they have more
Democrats in their District than that
and that is what is going to bring this
together around someone who can work
with Democrats even if even if McCarthy
were to eek out a Victor Steve scalise
or at least stefanik guess what they
can't move a bill
this is going to happen every time they
try and do anything keeping the
government open uh the debt ceiling all
the rest of it they can't do it they're
going to need Democrats and the best way
to do that is to find a coalition so I
could be Jeffries we understand that
it's got to be someone that enough
Republicans can live with and enough
Democrats can support and that person
gets 300 350 votes for speaker Jeffrey
and that it would be to me a great day
for American democracy
well and that's how democracy is
supposed to work that's how it's
designed it's by that design uh we're
looking at the as David Bender we're at
the top of the hour David the political
strategist David Bender is joining us
for our coverage of day two of Kevin
McCarthy losing uh badly
um as Donald's the the shadow nominee
here from the Republican side uh today
the first the first nominee that is uh
the foil of Kevin McCarthy or just
received his 20th vote so we're at the
same count
um against Kevin McCarthy that we were
at yesterday I'm not sure 75 votes is
that going to be is it going to be more
than 20 today you know I I don't
remember the alphabetical order gave to
you uh of where we are is that the last
of the 20. no I think so we're gonna go
over uh it could be but are there any
s's T's or down the of the W's that
voted against him yesterday
because because
um that that is significant here that if
he gets over 20 really it is a sign that
not only is Kevin McCarthy not not going
in a the right direction he's going in
the wrong direction and really
um exactly for Kevin McCarthy's
political career here if he loses this
vote by more than 20 uh against him he
really should absolutely stand up and
speak on the floor and tell them that he
does not want to be nominated because
his political career really is is
hanging in the balance here of even
being a congress person I believe
um that if you can't if you can't Ascend
the speaker days and days and days
getting voted no
um by a by a large percentage of your
caucus to not get you over
um why would your constituents even want
you to be okay well they'll keep voting
him in but he will this is all he's ever
wanted he'll quit he'll take a K Street
job he'll be out very quickly uh Gabe do
you see was there anyone after in the
s's or T's that
do we have a 21st vote out there from
yesterday
um look it up yesterday
let me see view details
I go to vote three let's see if I can
get anything while Gabe's looking that
up um I want to point out too that this
vote again is gonna have Jeffries with
more votes than McCarthy and Matt Getz
David Bender Matt Gantz actually said
yesterday he would rather now of course
Matt Gat says a lot of things and he
venmos a lot of people
um but yes he doesn't Matt Gad said
yesterday that he would rather have Jim
or excuse me uh Hakeem Jeffries B we've
got a uh no I think the old the last
person that voted for Jordan yesterday
was uh all well
who is this it was an S self it was uh
and we passed that yeah so there's no
one knew that I could see but on the
McCarthy side let's see if anyone would
jump over
uh oh you could see Jacob Womack
these are people that were Whitman
Wilson William I mean there's
significant amount of W's that are still
coming up they could at any point they
all voted for McCarthy yesterday yeah
they all voted for practice so to be
fair they probably will vote in that
same form and fashion today the key is
that Donald's didn't flip back he voted
for himself right well and and they're
at an impasse here and McCarthy is not
going to win they're not going to give
in
um and and the reason why David is
because we watched Lauren bobert give
away the um
when she confirmed what reporters were
saying about Kevin McCarthy basically
saying you're not getting any
concessions of my speakership
um and it was because people were going
in personally saying I want to be the
chair of this committee I want to have
this power I want you to give me this I
want you to give me that and they kept
going on they kept moving the goal post
as the manga Republicans do as trumpism
does they move the goal post that's what
fascism does it moves the goal post it
moves the goal post and moves golbos
um and that's when he threw up his hands
and that's why he is not going to get
um these 19 or 20. he's not going to get
him to vote for him is he threatened
them right at the end of that he said I
have earned this and he made it clear
they understand that if it's the old
expression of if you're going for the
king you better get him they know
they've gone for him and they they can't
let him win now because those 20 are all
going to be isolated so this is a game
of attrition
the Democrats are not going to play if
he moves to adjourn right now the
Democrats will not let them so they will
keep voting that's their requirement and
and if the Democrats are remember
yesterday they had their families there
yesterday the kids were all over the
floor yeah they were only changing
diapers on the floor exactly right and
and you know when you do that for Matt
Gates it takes a while because they're
big and they're ready
the point I would make is these people
are prepared now the Democrats to stay
well into the night and force this vote
to keep happening oh so you think you
think we the Democrats May Force this
until they absolutely can't stay awake
to adjourn uh come back tomorrow and
keep doing the same thing over and over
again until Republicans get their get uh
where I come from because getting your
[ __ ] together I think I think you said
it exactly right before what's going to
happen if this goes one more round and
they know that if they're not going to
move these 20 is McCarthy has to fall on
his sword
that's what has to happen and and he has
to take his name out of contention we
are in the W's here so 15 15 no 14 votes
left yeah so it looks like it looks like
uh it's gonna be 20 against McCarthy
again the number the same number that
we're going to have today that we had in
the third vote yesterday so vote number
three for McCarthy is going to be the
exact same result as vote number four
our four is same as three
um which is a sign that Kevin McCarthy
is not moving in the right direction
he's moving in the wrong direction he's
moving in no direction right now that's
and and he can't now get out of the
building yeah well he at least I I
believe this morning
um that number one he to become speaker
he needed to get this floor to adjourn
which he what he didn't accomplish today
um but his next best step was to
actually get maybe one or two to vote
present or not vote um which would have
gave a sign that hey maybe the caucus is
going to break in that way but he did
not get that here
um there's no change
the candidacy of Kevin McCarthy is on
life support it has not flatlined yet
but it's really close
and we're gonna see if they go through
this if they move quickly again to
another ballot
what is going to happen nothing is going
to change here those 20 just made it
clear they're not moving is that the
same boat that we had is that the same
vote
there's some people that still need to
vote right now they didn't answer the
first one okay so so they're gonna uh
they either weren't in the chamber or
didn't hear their names
yeah there's one person that did not uh
answer the first call to roll so maybe
there is one person that is abstaining
um which again may be a sign for
McCarthy that he's not it's not yet
voting present though
yeah there is one vote present
so here we are
here we are sparks uh I don't know uh so
this is a move yesterday this is um with
McCarthy it would have been 202 to 12
20.
um
that doesn't that doesn't help McCarthy
because right now if you do this math
and and tough people vote present on the
next go round to lower the number from
218 down to 212. and I'm not a I can't
do the math on the fly but call kornacki
he can I think I yeah well Gabe is our
cornacky here uh Gabe do you have your
khakis on or your corduroys on today
yeah yeah yeah okay good good you gotta
stand up we got to see him make sure I
don't actually have the khakis on I got
I got loose fitting shorts on right now
he didn't have pants on he didn't have
pants on David that's Patrick McHenry
watching on the camera right now the bow
ties Patrick McHenry of North Carolina
the person I suggested might be speaker
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait a second are you telling
me that there might be a chance David
Bender you're predicting there might be
a chance that we have a speaker who
wears bow ties because yeah
Carlson will start wearing bow ties
again how unhappy look at how unhappy
Donald's is right now he's held McHenry
came to him and said okay
now McDonald's is what the camera is
staying on him for for a reason
because what he does now
is going to determine whether this thing
holds at 20 remember he voted for
McCarthy the first two times and said I
only committed to Kevin for two ballots
and he kept his commitment then he he
flipped on the third he's now voting for
himself on the fourth what happens on
the fifth where he's now the man of the
moment uh no one thinks he's going to be
speaker but what he does here
and if he nominates someone
next we're going to get an idea of where
they're going next so Gabe Sanchez um
who was the present vote again
um and did did that person vote in the
first three ballots for McCarthy can we
confirm that yeah so Sports from Indiana
and uh she voted on the third one here I
can let me just but on the last one uh
yesterday's third vote she voted for
McCarthy my assumption is if I look back
I'll find her again on the first two
votes right this seems to be cracking so
so
um so the two people that are going to
be watched and
um whipped here on the floor is
definitely
um the present vote and Donald's here uh
as David is is saying because uh what
those two because if she if in the next
ballot she moves her vote back to
McCarthy instead of present
um that's a sign as well
um that there that this present thing is
not gonna work because I believe this
morning the math was
and Gabe correct me if you know this I
believe they need
um I believe that he needs from the 20.
he needs to get 20
um uh 11 of those 20 to move to present
to actually make this vote work and
lower and lower the number then he has
to pick up the rest of them right to get
to to get to 218. which I don't believe
he's going to be able to do here but
um what Donald's does and what uh you
say it Sparks Sparks
I misspoke by the way he wouldn't need
to get to 218. the 11 voting present
lowers the threshold right and they
would get him down
so 210 could win it right Nancy Pelosi
won it with 216. uh it's possible to do
this by lowering the numbers there were
this is not unprecedented but this
number of people needing to vote present
is unprecedented well the difference
between Nancy Pelosi and Kevin McCarthy
that the the obvious difference is Nancy
Pelosi probably doesn't know how to
count yeah one four two right but that
would be McCarthy math yeah but but but
but I'll tell you of house floor votes
like this it is difficult math it is
difficult map when you have house floor
votes like this
um it's it you actually have to
um be in Congress for a while or be
around a staff in staff to really
understand our government is very
complicated it is very complicated it is
there's a lot of gears at work here and
that's why McHenry is McHenry has been a
Deputy Whip for a long time that's why
you see him moving around talking to
people he was the first person over to
Donald's Patrick McHenry and he has been
one of the five designees from
McCarthy to try and work this
Fitzpatrick a few others and they they
know how to count McHenry does that's
been his job look at look at the throng
around Matt Gates yeah you see him him
whipping and you see you see Jim Jordan
also in the background there behind yet
um but he's having conversations body
posture is not like he's aggressive look
at no look at gats look how confident uh
King Jeffries is here yeah he's very
competent yes he has not Hakeem Jeffrey
has nothing to worry about at this point
other than making sure dims don't give
up on this and just uh call it a day and
leave that's not going to happen they're
not going anywhere they're completely
United it's a I watched an interview
with AOC last night and they're very
clear they have their issues uh with
Hakeem Jeffries but they are united as
one party because as you said this is a
party that stands for something this is
a party believes in governing these
other people stand against something or
believe in
actually making the house cease to
function yesterday
um there was a speaking of Matt gatz on
the floor there was a little back in AOC
I'm glad you brought this up Dave
there's a little spat back and forth
between them I'm not sure exactly what
was said maybe so she she no no no she
did did she so she yeah so she went on
to Instagram live last night and she was
talking about kind of what the process
is and she gave some clarification on
the conversations that were happening
she said it was a a very bizarre
conversation right because there's one
that she never really thought but
basically what was happening is you had
people like gosar and Gates coming up
and kind of getting a gauge on they they
threw out things that were untrue
so it sounded like they were throwing
out this position as like oh people were
going to move away from Jeffries and she
basically was like that's not gonna
happen that's I don't know where you
heard that I don't know who told you
that but so dance is trying to get this
water AOC to move away from Jeffrey
right to try to try to have some what
they want is some cannon fodder to say
well it's not just us in chaos look at
the right look at the difference exactly
but I want to show you um because maybe
um maybe or maybe not here let's see if
I can uh what okay here we're looking I
want I want to show you this is
um oh yeah that's a picture this is a
picture now this is from bad lip reading
this is from Bad Lip Reading David
Bender so this is what their
interpretation was of the lip reading so
let's take a listen to what this
conversation was I've heard that the
floor asks for shrubs to be put in the
comment areas yeah right we will not let
this lie because like obviously we you
know put in some rocks too
oh interesting
[Laughter]
so that is their interpretation of I
love that that's great I I this is a
Mystery Science Theater you know yeah uh
since you brought up Matt Gatson AOC I
wanted to make sure everyone knew that
that was the lip reading interpretation
I love that that's a great one as we go
back I mean can you imagine being
trapped and by the way talk about a
super spreader event yeah you're trapped
inside of a room with people who don't
believe that covet is real
uh and the what was the first thing they
did even though they don't have the
authority to do it there are two things
they've done without Authority one they
moved Kevin McCarthy into the speaker's
office yep which is completely wrong and
and in fact uh Matt gates to uh his
humorous credit uh sent uh an email to
the architect of the Capitol saying
excuse me how long is he going to be
there yeah when is he just uh squatting
in the uh in the speaker's office the
other thing they did instantly was they
pulled down the mags yep uh members of
Congress are no longer required to go
through uh metal detectors uh
magnetometers uh because you know why uh
if if Lauren bobert wants to bring her
gun onto the floor she can she probably
is now and that is that those are the
two things we've seen uh the actions of
this would be Congress one is to uh put
Kevin McCarthy in an office he does not
yet have uh because they don't believe
in the rule or this process that they
they assume power and they take it and
they and they also make it less safe
uh as a workplace uh there and this is
just you know day two
wait for it they took down the mags when
the children were on the floor well and
and
um in pure
um
I call them nincompoop Nazis and and
true nimkapoop style of Lauren bobert
um as they're removing them she makes a
social media video and that is that and
to point out that that she that they're
removing them as if it's some kind of to
own the libs type thing like it
continues to be this on the libs with
the mags and and again it's because
these are unserious people in serious
positions and they believe that their
job is a social media influencer and
having followers not like thinking about
policy and how it's going to affect the
American people and they're coming a
little bit you know so here's Kevin
McCarthy he looks he looks very happy
for losing for the fourth time I mean I
do have to say he's a great Pretender if
not anything he is a great Pretender
here he's leaving the chamber yeah he
looks like he's um maybe he's gotta use
the facilities or something I don't know
I mean you know I think he's done that
already and we just can't see the same
maybe maybe this maybe he's going to
Grandpa's snack I don't know Chex Mix
well uh uh Snickers bars out of energy
I'm honestly I'm surprised that he's
leaving like I would imagine someone
who's already squatting in an office
that isn't his he'd be very very adamant
about staying in his seat what I don't
understand Gabe just to your point
though is is leaving suggests that
they're not going to take another action
they are required uh once everybody has
been counted and they now have they have
420
434 34 what what do we got there well
this is 13400 this is 430 three
34 right with the present uh yeah yeah
yeah yeah 434 so everyone is voted the
minute that happens
unless they're in adjournment the clerk
is supposed to call another role
and I this is a pause I don't really
understand how uh I'd be curious to know
what they're saying because the
requirement is they have to keep voting
uh they're not allowed to just sort of
stand there
yeah so like each vote if I have the
countdown each vote takes about 45
minutes roughly right 40 to 45 minutes
and I think it's the recording of it
because you see the clerks here
recording right or they just had now
um one thing I want to point out because
the room mics are really terrible for
C-SPAN right like when you get a room
mic and that's why we can't hear the AOC
Matt Getz conversation that's
intentional right
um when you when you mic a room
um to hear the voices in the room it's
different than the way that C-SPAN is
Mike and there's a reason for that
that's why you see all this stuff on the
floor where they're they're holding
Court in other words there's this one
Congressman or congress versus standing
around and there's a bunch of people
standing around them and they're they're
giving a a monologue here and they're
they're what that is is that I mean they
may be sharing pictures like Matt Gantz
does on the floor of the house but more
than likely in this moment they're
whipping and they're trying to make sure
that Kevin McCarthy because my guess is
someone's going to nominate him and
someone else you see here on the floor
where there is she came talking right so
these are Democrats um strategizing on
the floor and that's why the room isn't
miked very well is because you know
we're not really it's not really privy
for for these conversations to get the
um to get the votes because that's what
politics really truly is oh he hasn't
left the room
he's he's standing by the door just in
case oh he's having a laugh
he's really enjoying himself this is
look if if he is pretending uh he's
doing a fine job this is the image that
you're supposed to put forward but
there's something wrong with this
picture and what it I I can't yet see
without having a mic down there or
having someone uh giving us their you
know just off the floor the reporters
are right outside those doors guys uh
and what happens when they go out is
someone and by the way members are
texting uh the media as well so if if
we've got an ear to uh MSNBC CNN we're
going to hear what they're saying about
the absence of movement
as soon as the clerk reads the results
of the fourth ballot
uh they've got to move and there's we
see Donald's now uh not clear he's still
his he's he's not looking as happy as
Kevin McCarthy right I think he's scared
this is a big deal he's now the center
of this remember he came late to the
party
uh he'd been for McCarthy and that now
he's he's Judas
so this is enough position to be in
English he's not going to be a speaker
but he doesn't know what his future
holds by yeah I mean you brought up a
good you brought up a good point
yesterday which is like you know if
you're gonna go for the king you you you
got to make sure that it's a it's a it's
a you know it's a kill you wait like
yeah yeah if you're if you're going to
be known as the person that you know is
Judas or uh or or stabbed Caesar in the
back let's say you better make sure that
it's a fatal blow and yes each one that
they're I mean obviously as we see we
see a present
um
vote happen which is like you know we're
you know some of the armor is beginning
to fall off of McCarthy it's not a lot
it's something but you know with descent
within the own his own party isn't
obviously a great sign for McCarthy
himself yeah but also if they don't take
him out it's not going to be a great
sign for any of one I mean like he's he
clearly has his own list now which is
anyone who voted against me
for what just happened if you think
about the math to get down to a
threshold where the presence allow him
to get enough votes to win
this just didn't happen that was a
McCarthy voter
and because she now switched to present
it didn't help him it was one less vote
he had right and and that's that's not a
good sign so in fact if we're counting
he had it's gone one more vote in the
other way away from McCarthy on this
four thousand well before we go back to
the floor I want to play this this is
last night on Fox News Tucker Carlson's
White Privilege tonight
um this is his take now uh the Trump
statement which gave if you can't I
think I might have it I think I got it I
could blow it up
um his statement from this morning where
he's saying close the deal vote for
Kevin I believe that's an extension from
what Tucker Carlson said last night
let's listen to what uh [ __ ] I mean
Tucker because they decided McCarthy is
not conservative enough to represent a
party that's just taken back the house
from Nancy Pelosi and they are
definitely right about that McCarthy is
not especially conservative he's in fact
ideologically agnostic he's flexible his
real constituency is the lobbying
community in Washington so if you've got
sincere political beliefs that is
infuriating to watch
on the other hand to be fair this is
politics and McCarthy does have
strengths it's not easy being speaker
when the house is this closely divided
and in some ways Kevin McCarthy is
perfectly suited for that he is skilled
in politics not a small thing and
critically McCarthy is willing to spend
the next two years living in hotel rooms
raising money for his party ahead of a
historic presidential election
what other Republican in the house is
willing to do that well as of tonight
and we have checked no one has stepped
forward so I believe what this is is
this is this is the dog asking the tail
what to do right
um they really don't know what what the
what their base wants here do they want
to appear not to be a bunch of losers
and can't form a government or do they
want to appear
um to to to be standing against non uh
Trump or or anti-trump or whatever and
here's the statement from Grandpa
Poopypants the Cheeto dust you and honor
this morning
um I'm not going to read the whole thing
but he goes into great Republican house
members to vote for Kevin close the deal
tape I mean he's in all capsues get down
to the bottom part though Tony that's
the fun part when it goes into lower
case and isn't streaming
if you notice here he says watch crazy
Nancy pelosian fly back home to very
broken California which cal um
California is where Kevin McCarthy is
from by the way but where he's from
specifically is Baker's field and for
anyone who doesn't know it's a it's just
a long stretch there's a bunch of Oasis
and there's Farms it's a bit of a dry
area there's not a lot going on down
there so you know I I don't know who
he's really representing but it's very
much a drive-through area as opposed to
a stop and oh look this place is so nice
and beautiful and actually you know
gives back well but he he gives the
Nancy Pelosi dig which came directly
from Tucker Carlson if you remember the
clip I just showed he dug on Nancy
Pelosi even though Tucker Carlson and
the same breath said it is it is a very
difficult job to manage a house
um with this slim majority which Nancy
Pelosi has done uh successfully but if
you get down to the bottom um where
Bender is talking about he says Kevin
McCarthy will do a good job in lower
case very very important and maybe even
a great job just watch so I mean that is
the ultimate vote of confidence he'll do
a good job
maybe it could be I don't know does
anyone want a cheeseburger what about a
bucket of KFC what do you think is that
good I don't know it's just it is
classic Donald Trump of you know Kevin
McCarthy came down to Mar-A-Lago revived
him after having said the only true
thing Kevin McCarthy has ever said the
only principal thing which is I'm done
with this guy and then it proceeded to
prostrate himself showing that he has no
principles he has no spine he has and
everybody knows that everybody on his
side knows that this is not a guy that
they believe in this is not a leader
this is someone who simply wants a job
much like Trump
has no agenda I I I think I think
yesterday it was reported that Kevin
McCarthy called and basically again put
on his Cheeto dust knee pads and begged
Trump
um to put this statement out and to give
him some sort of support and I believe
that is exactly the [ __ ] that Donald
Trump strives off of and is looking for
and that's why my belief is this
statement that we just read and you can
go read it on my Twitter it's there
um it's all [ __ ] Trump doesn't
believe any of that he doesn't really
have any kind of stake that Kevin
McCarthy would win and that the entire
Republican party would rally around him
where Trump really strives is chaos and
if he is responsible for the chaos
especially when he can blame someone
else for it that is where he lives in
the in his best self as he sees it
um that is what's what he strives off of
he just likes television this is all
teaming to him right and that's he lives
for television he's producing it is what
you're saying he's producing this chaos
for television and he's enjoying it
there's Donald's walking back through a
crowd someone is uh I don't know who
this is but is making an impassioned
case
Gates is listening to a conversation now
standing next to Jim Jordan uh oh that's
who's making the impassioned case
talking to Jordan uh Gates is listening
he's not arguing so what are we learning
from the the body language of this
they're saying hey we've got to do
something because we're going to get
stuck with Fred Upton and that's
something either Jordan or Gates wants
but particularly why wouldn't why
wouldn't they want a Fred Upton I mean
why is it will not let Jim Jordan run
wild with investigating by
that's what he may not even give him the
gavel the deal that would be made with
the Democrats is going to require that
uh Comer is not sharing oversight and
Jordan is not sharing Judiciary they
don't want that
this is all about the Committees this is
where the power is this is
decentralizing the power they all agree
on that they don't want a powerful
speaker they want to be like the Senate
where any one person the Joe manchin uh
Kirsten Cinema they want that's what
these uh 20 want they want the ability
for one of them to stand up and say
speaker has to go now don't like what
they're doing well in that gamble the
gamble gives them the gavel gives them
the the the guaranteed Fox News uh
highlights too that gives them the level
of the Committees
it gives it gives them the possibility
of every single day and every single
week having those Fox News moments on
Tucker Carlson's White Privilege tonight
where they're the hero because they they
slam dunk Joe Biden and Hunter Biden's
laptop or whatever the hell they're I
like that white privilege tonight yeah
well that in that what it's called game
Sanchez it is I think sorry I was I was
just getting a I was just getting a
photo of McCarthy from an inside scoop
he went to go clean himself up from the
bathroom oh yeah yeah and uh this is the
photo I was given
oh my god oh oh man yeah he's looking
pretty pretty bad right yeah well he
came out of the bathroom
yeah he cleaned up looks like he put
some makeup on
yeah it's helpful to have people forget
these things you know I
what what is happening right now is
Pete trying to make the case
for how the next vote will be different
than the last vote right um if you watch
uh David I don't mean interrupted if you
watch at least stephanic and Kevin
McCarthy here they don't look too
confident in this image
um and they have been Elise has been
helping him direct
um because she is a Maga Trump
Republican she wasn't at first she
became she genuflected to Trump uh very
quickly when she took office
um but
um they don't look too confident as this
is going to go to a fifth vote here no
uh it's it I I'm gonna say I'm not going
to read into their body language because
it's it's so hard to tell what is going
on but in in the lower corner of our
screen we see um
is the congressman from Oklahoma Tom
Cole who has often been talked about as
one of the people who might be a company
a very powerful Congressman by the way
because he's been in Congress for a long
time he he has a big stick and he
carries it so well I I I you know I I
mean much now that you don't have a MAG
we don't know what he's carrying let's
go with that yeah I I was trying to tone
that one down for you even though we're
not FCC
we can say whatever the [ __ ] we want
David
say whatever the [ __ ]
that what I'm wondering and I wonder
Dave if you can get any intel uh if
anyone's tweeting about this
why it's taken so long this is different
than uh
yesterday they pretty much read the call
and the clerk moved to another vote
right you think with a quorum they would
move back to regular order here they
should yeah yeah the votes are all
recorded they're not waiting for
anything else well you know you know
David uh go ahead go ahead no so I was
uh I was just looking at uh Scott
McFarland and see if we can get an
update from him he goes
seven minutes ago he said more
discussions on the house floor involving
uh representative Jim Jordan now
speaking with a group of McCarthy GOP
defectors including uh rep Mary Miller
and rep Andy Harris
so I don't know let me see where those
I'm assuming some sort of factors then
they have been voted against him in this
last round but I don't know if that's
any indication of them voting present in
the next round but I'll keep looking
that's what McCarthy that's what
McCarthy really has to do here to win
this is he has to move those 20 in two
columns he has to move them into and
votes for him and votes present
um which basically those 20 are should
View at least because this is how Maga
and the tail that Wags the dog is going
to is going to Penn it on them is that a
vote for present in in a McCarthy win is
a vote for McCarthy
um that is important here in the in what
they're trying to manage here because
what they're trying to manage is that is
that Maga isn't too mad at them they
don't want to lose their crazy Coalition
Tony I beg to differ with respect okay
go ahead a vote from one of the previous
McCarthy voters voting for president is
not well that is true that is true it
has to be one of those 20 voting present
this is one less in the total from
organic she moved away from McCarthy
she'd move to Donald's but she moved
away from a Carthage so you're saying
maybe maybe she moves into the the foil
category in this next I mean that's the
direction she's moving eventually it's
it's hard to say but she it was one less
vote McCarthy hat that's right bottom
line and we also don't know do they go
round two for Donald's or do they throw
up a new name they just said house will
be in order here so let's go back that's
good no and there has been a big huddle
uh in the middle of the house between
moderates and the right
um that's been going on for the last 15
minutes
the votes cast
is
433. okay so they're confirming the last
tally The Honorable
[Applause]
Still The One winner the winner of the
vote the winner of the vote not the seat
of speaker but well he's gone yeah and
he's gone four rounds he's won every
round so far hasn't won the speakership
yet but and you know he he is a new he's
a new leader he's the new leader of the
democratic caucus so that's pretty good
fornia has received 201
. I was talking to McHenry now
the bow tie
he looks like a speaker of the house
doesn't he I don't know I'm just saying
and one member has voted present
[Applause]
would one member elect
recorded as present
and that's important too remember
electives they haven't been sworn in
well yeah they're all voting we're all
numbers
but what purpose does the gentleman from
Ohio seek recognition looks like Jim
Jordan
nominate Kevin Mark Kevin McCarthy as
Speaker of the House no different Ohio
you know who this is I'm not really sure
now why would I
why would I as a conservative
Davidson eighth District the house
Freedom caucus backed in a in a
congressional race
why would I nominate Kevin McCarthy to
become the next speaker of the house
he's been in office since 2016. Jim
Jordan
why would other conservatives like
Thomas Massey Jim Banks Kevin Hearn and
others support Kevin McCarthy
as Speaker of the House in vayner's Old
seat you know something in our nature as
humans
causes us to dehumanize others when we
engage in Conflict
dehumanizing others makes it easier Rich
coming things them the things that chip
Roy yesterday and Jim Jordan my God the
projection coming out of their mouths
disagreement we're going to get real
things done you had an opportunity last
year and you guys didn't do anything
what could Steve scalise and Elise
stefanik down to the left scalise is
looking up at him going okay you get one
more try at this and then when does my
name go into nomination yeah
let cooler more rational heads prevail
let us know
you know Speaker of the House
unlike Democrats nearly every Republican
at least campaigns on some form of
smaller more accountable government
but you can't govern
become less free less safe and more
burdened by debt the American people are
sick and tired of it
and they keep sending us reinforcements
reinforcements that today
help make up our small majority
but a majority is only a majority if we
actually work together
now lots of back home lots of people
back home don't trust anyone in this
town
[Laughter]
wise to listen to them
and some wisdom from Ronald Reagan
oh breaking out the old quotes
opposed
Kevin McCarthy as Speaker of the House
I will now demonize
the issue is this
they do not trust Kevin McCarthy
what can heal that divine he wow
he just said the quiet part out loud he
just nominated and then he said he just
nominated and said he's a great leader
but 20 people don't trust him
they're jokes they're absolute jokes
it's just right now insanity
an actual majority of the House Freedom
caucus members do support Kevin McCarthy
this summer a unified House Freedom
caucus started the negotiations with a
proposal for new rules a different way
to govern that empowers committees and
regular members we propose that a set of
tools could be structured to make trust
more verifiable constructured
not a word they use the best of words
Kevin McCarthy engaged in that
negotiation he led the conference to
adopt substantive reforms that will make
our majority more effective
let me list some of them
Andrew Clyde's proposal to restore
public access to the Capitol Lauren
bober's proposal to reduce the linkage
between the nrcc and the steering
committee process Gary Palmer's proposal
to the cap spending on suspension bills
Ralph Norman's proposal to limit
leadership reports and make conference
more about engaging all members chip
Roy's proposal to provide a five-day
notice for suspension votes Dan Bishop's
proposal in privileged resolutions Scott
Perry's proposal for additional
conference meeting you notice none of
these things benefit the American people
only members of Congress Appropriations
bills Andy Biggs proposal limiting
everything labors almost seems like they
have themselves in mind when they're
asking for things no sponsored
amendments in order
a firm 72-hour publication ability
what's remarkable here is that they're
showing each pound of Flesh
of Kevin McCarthy and they're
enumerating it rule cut go instead of
pay go and into unblock suspension votes
a major reform worked out with Morgan
Griffin what we hope to call the Griffin
rule on single subject bills subject to
Jermaine's germanness points some of
these rules gentlemen are a disaster for
the American people absolutely well
they're put forward by Republicans I
mean well some of the military committee
[Music]
these rules make it impossible
almost seems in exemptible for him to
become speaker
committee answers that question with
oversight and Leadership by our most
effective member my friend and colleague
the future chairman of the house
Judiciary Committee Congressman Jim
Jordan oh my God we as Republicans are a
big and diverse conference no you're not
yeah I know you're not can we accept
incremental progress can we work for a
victory one person no one time no you
can't can we only accept the high risk
trick plays yeah can we set about the
hard work of winning debates with our
colleagues nope as
fun through this process no you haven't
can we take
nope and give hope you're losers women
of America who no longer believe this he
finally mentions the American people
finally
we're having achieved nearly everything
yeah that we've asked for
including is he tweeting see if he's
tweeting
resolution
does it really boil down to this that 20
or more of my colleagues will never
trust Kevin McCarthy as Speaker yes yes
there's been four votes damn it
you know I think Kevin McCarthy has lost
this speaker vote more than Trump lost
Arizona at this point right am I right
about that well remember that it took
nine votes and 23 is like as I recall it
as you were there remembering it yes
I think
it can't get much Beyond this words and
I nominate Kevin McCarthy Jim Jordan
looks like he's tweeting from the
Judiciary committee's account he's he's
he's uh he's probably tweeting
McCarthy Elon Trump yeah
yeah
I didn't I didn't tweet that that
tweet's been deleted yeah okay okay Jim
Jordan
by the way Jim I don't report sex crimes
Jordan as I call him here on the show
Madam clerk Pete Aguilar is back
do it one more time I I do this again
my my guess is I'm going to turn this
down a bit because I want to talk to you
um
because
uh Edgar lawyer here is gonna give the
same kudos to uh Kim Jeffrey says he's
been it's gonna be quick too yes
to seek an abortion into law like all of
us
like all of us Hakeem has spoken about
consistently the disastrous Dobbs
decision
time and time again message but it is
well past time to codify Roe v Wade into
law and he knows that young women should
not grow up in a world with fewer rights
than their parents and grandparents
equality inequity imagine crazy use each
of these moments
for what we stand for directed by the
caucus to present for election Hakeem
Jeffries representative elect do you
notice how he said that in David Bender
he's directed by the caucus in other
words they're unified they are not
moving they're not going anywhere you
people have to pick a speaker you have
to pick a speaker do your job and govern
do it now there's Catherine Clark and
you know you got to hand it to stenny
Hoyer who has wanted to be speaker
forever Lauren bobert's going to
Congress
Congressman Donald
's okay all right so we're gonna go with
Donald's uh all day today what does she
have to say I hope she shows her gun my
friend pew pew an amazing man of Florida
an amazing leader someone who almost
even took leadership do you think she
just met Byron Donalds yeah I guarantee
she just met him on the floor she
reminds me a lot of Sarah Palin just
meeting John McCain
uh it was the same he's a Maverick she's
they say he's a Maverick yes lipstick
pigs and Mama bears that's what I'm
gonna go you know
gentlemen I was there for the moment in
St Paul when Sarah Palin was introduced
to the Republican party and no one had
ever heard of her the night before
they came out frothing so happy
do you remember why do you remember why
what happened here's here's what
happened that day Rush Limbaugh went on
the air and Rush Limbaugh had no idea
who she was and Rush Limbaugh all but
endorsed everything she's ever done and
ever touched and she was going to be the
greatest president when John McCain died
that's what he said basically that I
listened to him that day when he said it
and uh that's what what gave her her
Ascension you I I have to say you you
have much stronger components than me I
I couldn't listen to rush for more than
you know a minute I listened to him for
years I of course I vehemently disagree
with everything he said but I'll tell
you if you wanted to know exactly what
Republicans were gonna say you listened
to rush and they would say it and um I
listened to him up until 2016 because he
genuflected to Trump like I've never
seen him genuflect any other person
before and I couldn't it was it wasn't
Rush anymore it was just a trump issue
and then at that point he started
getting sick at which point Trump gave
him the medal of freedom
and security which is a disgrace this
almost bigger disgrace than his bus
being in the capital of Missouri in our
state but too often our efforts have fun
deaf ears our border is wide open in
places
the same old Republican lies so let me
let me well see the Senate just passed
1.7 without our input basically saying
Kevin McCarthy gave away the store
even though he posed it for eight hours
on the floor look this is this is simply
what they're doing to get Kevin McCarthy
if they don't move in our country
this will go on what we were elected
to bring a bed in here but I'll tell you
it's going to go on all night and there
will come a point where they realize
record very soon one or two more votes
where uh
Byron Donald's Steve scalise's name
that's what we're going to see a play
when when the crack comes in those 20s
yeah it's gonna be because somebody else
has been able to get their votes I doubt
that it's Steve scalise but he's next in
line see him as someone who can this is
gonna communicate what we are the one
thing that I I think about right now is
the fact that you've got Akeem Jeffries
you know so much more black man
for the first time running for this
position and someone after last night
and the leadership uh because there was
a vote for Donald thrown out earlier on
but not actually backing him as a as a
candidate here
uh part of me is almost thinking that
this is less of like a we have faith in
this person but more of like a political
move to say well we also have a black
man too so they said that actually
yeah okay they said you know I I think
it was uh chip Roy who got up and said
let's let's note this first time two
black Americans have ever been nominated
and it's not and the thing is like it's
not that it's one of those things where
where you think like oh are we actually
creating equality I don't know if you
just noticed this there was a little bit
of Buffalo here
um and when Lauren bobert she said I
yield you have to yield back is the
actual
um phrasing Lauren bobert doesn't even
know how to yield uh her time she you
have to say yield back she said yield
several times and then the clerk had to
say do you yield back yeah and she said
yes do you know the process no Do You
Know the Way to San Jose
really it's just I mean hey hey it's
better than Ted Cruz knowing the way to
Cancun you know so so here's here's what
we're gonna see we'll see the the
question of whether or not there's any
movement uh and the important thing I
would say Tony about Donald's the reason
that they've rallied around him is he
became the 20th he's the only uh
McCarthy vote that flipped on that third
ballot right and they made him the
centerpiece to keep him from flipping
back
do you think do you think though that um
his flip was intentional for today
I mean no I think his I think just it
just played into this whole oh see we
got a black guy too we got a black guy
too he voted against McCarthy so now
we're gonna put him up he had I I think
they figured that part out but the the
reason that he gave and I'll take him to
this word here he had pledged to
McCarthy for two ballots
he didn't like McCarthy but he gave him
a vote for two ballots and McCarthy
couldn't close the deal after two he
decided to abandon him he was the only
one he's the only one that made that 19
into 20. but what they don't want to see
the Donald's people now they don't want
to see their numbers shrink
and that's what we're looking at in this
fifth round we're looking at whether or
not
that Donald's number is going to hold a
20. the uh one voting president from
Indiana will continue to do that
uh we're gonna get to Biggs who I
believe is the first vote
uh alphabetically in the Donald's or or
the Anthony McCarthy caucus well I'm up
against the uh the top of the hour here
um and if you if the audience won't oh
see there are you still there I'm here
no I'm here what happened was is I've
gone too long watching this too long it
and wants to know if if I want to
continue watching which I feel like is
the only time C-SPAN you know I feel
like the most amount of attention has
been given to C-SPAN this last year
alone just from the Jan six hearings and
also from this c-span's like whoa whoa
people are actually watching for
extended periods of time right Biggs has
voted uh he just he just voted
oh he just voted right there we've seen
it on the screen
um I I've got the sound off because
again we're I'm up against the clock
here and I appreciate you joining us for
almost the entire show I'm I'm thrilled
by it this is a moment in history that
that you know we will all share and
we're only that I were drinking because
I would drink with you
I mean if this goes on to until morning
I might have to happen in the morning
and let me say all of them uh wish they
could be drinking right now well I'll
tell you the audience in Gabe Sanchez
knows this Wednesdays is my day to you
know let loose so I am definitely
drinking tonight because it's Wednesday
but I might have other reasons to vote
they're still going to be voting tonight
yes
you take a drink every time Donald's
gets a vote
do we know because yesterday they
stopped after three they're like okay
we're just gonna call it right do we
know if they'll do the same today or
they're gonna just yeah Gabe again and I
know you're up against the top of the
hour but let me just say yeah they can't
adjourn unless they can get a majority
to adjourn
they have to keep voting
all right so we're already at four we're
got the same it's the same old folks
it's going to be the same old vote
um maybe the president will move into
the Donald's category maybe move back to
McCarthy may be able to stay in the
prison but we're gonna have the same
exact outcome here for the fifth vote uh
David Bender is protecting uh predicting
that we will either go into the night
and keep voting or if if Kevin McCarthy
really does withdraw and he walks away
from this um that could create a whole
new storyline in this crazy timeline
that we actually live in in the
intersection of WrestleMania and real
life
um that we are living through in our
American democracy but folks I want you
to understand something as we go this
truly is what you're seeing here is
democracy and you should watch it you
should try to pay attention to it today
if not just look at these final votes
and just internalize why it is so
important that you go to a ballot and
and give your own vote to the
representative of your government it is
you you are the government and this is
what happens when you put someone to go
vote and represent you who cannot form a
congress who cannot form a portion of
our legislative branch the 118 Congress
that's why that's why I am so passionate
about democracy and leaning into it and
making sure that I provide you a way of
seeing what democracy looks like through
a different lens than what the media
provides what other pundits provide I
think it's very important in our history
that that we have to see the bare raw
bones of what our democracy is and we're
seeing it here we're seeing it play out
and we're seeing that the Republicans
because they do not want democracy
democracy is their enemy that it is
working against their authoritarian ways
um and I I think I think if we keep
watching this we keep paying attention
we keep holding them accountable
whichever way it is whether it's me
yelling and screaming on a microphone
and having David and gabier to join me
or it's you Tweeting are you talking to
your family and family members they
probably don't know what's going on in
Washington today you can go download and
I don't get paid we're not a sponsor a
C-SPAN but you can go download the
C-SPAN app on your phone and you can
watch this live on your phone on the
C-SPAN app you can go to c-span.org and
watch this play out this truly is
democracy uh playing out in front of
your face
um and and I actually believe that it is
the beauty of our democracy what is
happening uh this is not is it
detrimental to our national security do
we need a congress yes but this is the
beauty of what our framers had in mind
and why they gave the power to us in the
House of Representatives because that's
truly who has the powers we have the
power of the House of Representatives
because in two years in 2024 we have the
power to change this Congress well this
non-congress I guess I should say
because we're not at 118 gun so David
Bender thanks for joining us give us one
last word before before we go the word
is math
and that's the word uh that we should
all be employing count those numbers
Nancy Pelosi can count we can all count
and if that 20 holds or 21 if you count
the present uh there is no future for
Kevin McCarthy as a speaker
well a lot of people said Kevin McCarthy
will never be speaker and it's beginning
more and more to look that way thank you
David Benner for joining us thank you my
friend as always it's great to have you
um maybe you can come back next week or
the week after or maybe the week after
that when we finally have a speaker of
the house we can talk about who the new
speaker is I am available anytime that
we know this thing is going to come to a
close I'd love to do this that's that's
great that's great everyone make sure to
subscribe here on YouTube do not miss a
single episode of the Tony Michaels
podcast we broadcast every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch and simulcast from
the Midas touch Facebook page head over
on over to our Facebook page at the Tony
Michaels now follow us there download
every single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify and
Google make sure to leave us a great
review while you're subscribing to your
favorite directory you know what while
you're downloading apps go get the
Twitch app why not it's free I don't get
paid for some people say I should get
paid on Twitch I'm not sure I need to
figure that out but um but as you go
download it Twitch app is free and you
can watch it there it's a different kind
of chat but also follow us on Twitter
because we're gonna have bone net of the
week poll this week and I know there's
going to be plenty of bonus Oh Yeah from
games ninjas so follow us at Tony
Michaels potty you can also vote this is
up to six he can't win
five it's official right before we we
leave the show Kevin McCarthy is 0-5 I'm
sure Gabe Sanchez will be posting a
picture of what he looks like when he
returns to the facilities
um to to recover himself everyone thanks
for joining us same time same place
tomorrow Surf's Up [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon